hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle we believe
with our eyes you can write a long
article about something but it will be
less convincing than a short note with a
bright photo because photos speak louder
than any words now we also share them
more often and discuss them more that's
why any really amazing photos should be
treated with absolute caution
[Music]
if you think that fake photos are an
achievement of modern technologies then
you are deeply mistaken the first edited
images appeared almost simultaneously
with the appearance of photos themselves
look at this portrait of abraham lincoln
this image was published by william pate
in 1865 almost immediately after the
assassination of the 16th president of
the united states the portrait became
incredibly popular and sold thousands of
copies across the country and only a
hundred years later the photographer and
writer stefan loren noticed a very
strange thing a large mole on the
president's cheek turned out to be in
the wrong side of his face lauren
compared the image with other photos of
lincoln and came to the conclusion that
the president's face was cut from a
picture of anthony berger which was
taken a year earlier this portrait is
probably quite well known to you well
because until 1999 it was printed on
every single five dollar bill now this
discovery inspired lorent to continue
the investigation and soon he found the
original image in the library of
congress it turned out that the artist
had superimposed the president's face
onto the portrait of john calhoun which
he had done 10 years earlier i doubt
very much that lincoln would have liked
it i mean cullen was a zealous supporter
of the preservation of slavery and he
often expressed very racist viewpoints
now the artist had to flip the
president's face over to fit calhoun's
heroic pose and this is how one of the
most famous portraits of lincoln
appeared
[Music]
this technique is actually used even now
for example a photo of john lennon
seemingly playing the guitar with
ernesto j guervara was actually edited
in this way which did make quite a
ruckus in fact the face of the cuban
revolutionary was superimposed on the
head of wayne gabriel the guitarist from
elephant's memories now this edit
quickly spread around the web and still
often pops up in articles regarding the
rebellious spirit of john lennon and
people are not even thrown off by the
fact that che guevara was killed in
1967. lennon was much younger then than
he looks in the picture comparison and
facts checking helps to identify such
fakes it's enough to find photos of john
lennon at that time and everything then
just falls into place that image of
lennon with che guevara eventually came
from the early 70s
[Music]
this search also brings us to another
famous fake you might have seen this
before albert einstein riding a bicycle
against the background of an exploding
atomic bomb seems pretty unlikely i mean
but all you have to do is just search
for albert einstein riding a bike and
immediately you'll find the original
photos of the great scientist it turns
out that this picture was actually taken
back in 1933 which is actually 12 years
before the first explosion of the atomic
bomb but finding a picture that served
as the background for this installation
is a little more difficult
i mean ordinary search queries for
example atomic bomb tests will give too
many different images it takes too long
to just look through them one by one
much like loren did when he was looking
for a portrait of lincoln that's why i'm
cheating her a bit i'll cut out a
fragment and i'll try to actually run
this through tinai this is actually
called reverse image searching i chose a
fragment with people sitting to the left
of einstein this includes more
noticeable details and it has a higher
contrast well when we compare the crowd
on the right of course the suspicious
part of the photos should not get into
the search fragment otherwise the search
engine will give me links to well just
fake pictures which i don't want well
tinai did not disappoint after a couple
of seconds i learned that this photo
of the explosion was taken in 1962 as a
landfill in nevada this explains the
presence of the audience in the frame
the test site was located near las vegas
and casino visitors were actually
offered excursions to visit the nuclear
bomb test amazing isn't it
[Music]
this photo that you see right now
appeared a few days after the september
11th terrorist attack oh there's another
one another plane just hit
right oh my gosh another plane has just
hit it hit another building it flew
right
[Music]
the description claimed that the picture
was taken by camera that the rescuers
had recovered from the wreckage of the
world trade center the photo quickly
became a sensation and it went viral
despite the fact that the model of the
boeing was completely wrong i mean the
757 instead of 767
but first journalists found a photo of
the plane that was used for this edit
and then of course the author himself
confessed peter goosley took the
original picture on the observation tech
of the world trade center four years
before the terrorist attack and then the
young guy decided to play a prank on his
friends and added the first plane he saw
to the old photo the joke quickly spread
throughout the web and many took it at
face value
anyway sometimes additional images are
not actually needed for the edits take
place the necessary fragments are
actually taken from the same image and
they're put together as a mosaic
effectively this isn't always easy to
detect so they're actually special
services for detecting these kinds of
fakes
[Music]
take a look at this photo for instance
it shows the test of the iranian she had
three missiles
it looks quite threatening right
but the reality is kind of different
let's check this picture of traces of
editing to do that i'm going to upload
the file to the online service called
forensic in the clone search mode it
becomes clear that the launch of the
third rocket was fabricated from
fragments of others in the picture now
these pink lines show the places in the
picture that are the same they're not
just similar but literally repeat
themselves with pixel accuracy in fact
the actual launch looked like this the
picture on the right was published later
and then the whole world was laughing at
iranian journalists the same technology
is used to search for fakes of let's say
invoices or bank documents i mean if
there are absolutely identical areas in
the photo then it means that there was
some kind of cloning involved the noise
of the camera matrix and the features of
the jpeg photo format itself exclude the
possibility of accidental coincidences
right
[Applause]
sometimes photographers face a different
task not to add something new but to
actually remove it altogether moreover
people learned how to edit photos like
this long before the advent of computers
my fellow historian and writer david
king wrote one of the most sinister
books that has ever fallen into my hands
and it's called the commissioner
vanishes the falsification of
photographs and art in stalin's russia
now in it he collected samples of how
stalin's enemies just disappeared they
disappeared in the literal sense of the
word but also disappeared from photos i
mean just take a look at this photo
there are four
then three
then two and then finally there's just
stalin do you notice how the background
changes in the place of the disappearing
people well for these pictures they were
literally scraped off of the film and
then the background was finished now
this is clearly the finest and most
precious of work but now it's much
easier to do this than before we
encounter erasing tools no less often
than we do copying tools but the
background in the place of the
disappeared objects is still able to
play a cruel joke nevertheless
take a look at this rolling stone cd
cover nothing suspicious right just a
concert photo take a closer look at the
lower part of the microphone stand
you'll see to the left of it there's
actually a wire that disappears behind
the neck of mick jack as a guitar a
trifle
well in fact this is all the remains of
the bass guitarist bill wyman he played
with the band as a session musician for
30 years but he was never officially a
member of the rolling stones therefore
the producers simply erased him from the
cover his solution is in the spirit of
stalin don't you think
and now let's try to determine fakes
with the help of mathematics
can you guess what's missing from this
edited photo of martin luther king
[Music]
well i'm going to upload this photos
forensically and use a different edit
search mode it's called error level
analysis now it's based on the features
of the photo compression algorithm every
time you save a photo as a jpeg the
format editor makes a lot of
calculations it breaks the image into
small blocks and then simplifies them
replacing a large amount of information
about each point with the results of
mathematical processing so to speak
therefore jpegs take up much less space
than uncompressed say dot bmp or dot raw
files but we're not going to go into the
subtleties of the algorithm the main
thing is to understand that each save
you make adds characteristic noise and
compression errors if the photo is not
edited such errors will look familiar
but changes have been made and therefore
the nature of the errors change
you can see straight away an anomaly
between the thumb and the middle finger
you see the errors around the fingers
are clearly heterogeneous it feels like
someone has walked over it basically
with an eraser so through tinai i found
the original image which really
confirmed my assumption some joker on
the internet really erased the index
finger from king's hand but they clearly
didn't expect me to use the error level
nasus method now this is how the
unedited photo should look in fact error
level analysis is a powerful tool for
finding fakes if you're interested in
this tool i recommend that you take a
training course on the website of
another online service for detecting
fake photos called photoforensics.com
[Music]
now i was particularly impressed by this
example if someone asked me what was
suspicious about this photo i'd have
answered that it was probably the vr
helmet on the tube right but in fact the
author of the photo himself drew a
completely different object
the analysis shows that there was no
mask on that guy in the photo i
definitely wouldn't have guessed it
before of course error level analysis
isn't the only algorithm for finding
edits other algorithms also help to
identify fake for example noise analysis
can point out inserted objects through
looking at the differences in noise
density luminance gradient determines
the direction of the lighting sources
for every object within the image and if
they don't match well it's a good
indication that you're looking at a fake
systems for the automatic detection of
forge documents are built based on these
very algorithms remember we tested them
out in one of the first videos well
think about how such a system looks at
your passport very much in the same way
that we saw king's photo in general even
if you're not going to become a forensic
expert understanding the principles of
digital editing analysis will help you
to identify fake even by eye
before the advent of personal computers
photo editing remains to be only really
a professional gig right but today any
student can launch a viral image a few
mouse movements and you've got yourself
another sensation right could be shot
falling plane a shark on the highway or
a castle on a rock in thailand fake
photos are used everywhere in
advertising political struggles and even
environmental campaigning but how can
you avoid the base information scammers
well just be critical of any information
you see if you see something that's
sensational think about whether it
violates the laws of physics or known
facts look for photos of the same event
from other sources and evaluate their
sort of correspondence with one another
now if you've been sent an important
document let's say a large invoice or a
suspicious receipt don't be lazy check
it for cloning elements pay attention to
the details disappearing wires curved
walls unusual shadows or unusual
reflections these are all great reasons
to doubt the authenticity of the picture
that you're looking at
now if the photo raises doubts or seems
vaguely familiar try to find individual
parts of it stock images are used in a
lot of these kind of edits right search
for fragments via google or tin i is a
good one we've talked about that and
finally if your doubts haven't
disappeared check the photo through
photo forensics or forensically this
will require some effort on your part
but in the eyes of your friends you'll
look like a real forensic expert
basically don't believe your eyes
they'll sometimes trick you unless of
course you're watching the some sub
channel with bradley as your host
everything we do here is honest so as i
said my name is bradley i hope you've
enjoyed another perilous prickly and
perky journey through the deep dark
depths of the online jungle and i will
see you soon
[Music]